you don't often see many black judges in
nevada courtrooms but that is slowly
starting to change that's right organa
introduces us to two local
african-american judges who have made
history
and explains just how they're
encouraging the next generation
i think it's very important that the
court represent this community
trailblazer icon judge tierra jones
balances tons of titles thanks to her
historic
position of power i became the first
african-american woman to sit on the
state court bench in the state of nevada
that happened in 2017 jones tells me her
diversity brings a different perspective
to the courtroom
something extremely essential as
african-americans continue to be
disproportionately incarcerated
one of the reasons i wanted to be a
judge is to make a difference it's my
job to follow the law but there's also
always
different life experiences and different
things that
are a part of your culture that are a
part of your background
that you bring to your everyday
decisions there are 58 judges in
nevada's eighth judicial district court
which serves clark county
jones is one of five african americans
currently on that bench
some were just elected in 2020 i
officially started on january 4.
dee butler is the first african-american
judge in clark county district court's
family division
it is nice to be the first but hopefully
not the last
she says growing up she never saw judges
that looked like her but witnessing
tierra jones first as a public defender
then as a judge
inspired her campaign when you're
talking about
mentors just life mentors attorney
mentors and then now
a judge mentor she is a key person
that i look up to jones also does a lot
of work with the valley's youth and says
she sees it as a responsibility
i think it's super important that i pave
the way for those who come after me
but she knows the road to representation
is a marathon
not a sprint and blazing a trail takes
time
i think we are definitely making
progress but there's definitely still
work that needs to be done
orco mana 8 news now